ce quota un décisif pour le sort
institutionnel du territoire en nouvelle
calédonie le troisième référendum
d'autodétermination aura lieu avant la
fin de cette année annonce ce mercredi
du ministre d autres mr sébastien
lecornu
une victoire du oui permettra de
préparer l'exercice de la pleine
souveraineté
en cas de victoire du non il faudra
élaborer un nouveau statut pour la
nouvelle calédonie elle qui devra être
approuvé par un nouveau référendum à
l'issue d'une semaine de discussions à
paris les élus calédoniens semblent
satisfaits écoutez c'est la première
fois
elle est pourtant moi je suis le dossier
comme un début presque 40 ans maman
c'est la première fois que le
gouvernement français s'est autant
investi à la préparation d'une mission
telle que nous avons vécue aujourd'hui
en mobilisant des ministres en
mobilisant des directions 2016 a fait
trop vers l'armée et ses acteurs pour
éclairer notre éclairer le oui puisque
non défendant le oui voilà en tout cas
je suis satisfait de cela nous nous
étions pour dérouler de l'accord
jusqu'en 2022 nous sommes battus comme
d'habitude argument contre argument pour
défendre notre position dans vos
décéléré en août en parlant 2022 2018
sommiers 2000 quand le second et le
troisième finalement
alléché dans la discussion ce n'est pas
lui ce n'est pas cette option a été
retenue par le gouvernement français qui
est seul compétent en la matière pour
organiser leur album et on va fixer la
date
le gouvernement a fixé la date du
prochain référendum le 12 décembre
nous allons nous y tenir ce lien avec la
france et maintenant selon moi garantie
que le nom l'emportent
évidemment il nous faudra un nouveau
statut faudra changer la constitution il
faudra faire évoluer notre relation avec
avec la métropole mais et puis maintenir
le droit à l'autodétermination pour que
les indépendantistes ne perdent pas bien
sur l'aspiration auquel à leur politique
et si c'est un luis de la même manière
et on ne peut pas imaginer non plus une
calédonie qui se détache de la france ce
serait aussi souhaité par personne à
commencer par moi mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on peut aussi se dire sur
la nationalité sur les compétences
régaliennes sur ceux des transferts
il y a des discussions aussi qui peuvent
permettre de maintenir ce lien